we've got a voicemail number 219 to
david p let's take a listen to the
voicemail that came in Oh pacman uh
what's up Lu easiest role here as a
going ah yeah so I went to your website
i could actually become a member to her
about that hand corner very great
website very clean um notice something
interesting though I had gone through
you know last year's video of them
healed as I noticed a few videos about
how a Columbus Day was evil I guess that
was a you know kind of a talk a little
coffee for a year ago it turns out you
took a girl should so I decide to hit
the critical of you that you would you
know come out so so uh there is Lee
against the holiday it's evil Chris
percolo you just blow you kill all these
Native Americans and you know we
wouldn't be here having to show it to
warm him but no we hate about enough but
but you take it off yeah what I
hypocrite you are pac-man so shameful
all right thing about listen uh we take
federal holidays off work life balance
is important i think that there is no
way on any on any reasonable planet
where Christmas a Christian holiday
should be a federal holiday but we take
it off I mean did that that's what it is
I don't know that there's anything too
crazy going on here Pat plus I don't
think there's any hypocrisy you can just
argue that Columbus Day should be
changed to be like indigenous peoples
day or something and change the name of
the holiday we still want a holiday in
October that we take off no doubt about
it also I just love how excited he is
about his own title hey Louisiana troll
here yeah the Louisiana troll has
started calling way more frequently
since we've named him the Louisiana
troll you might not know that because
most of his voicemails just get deleted
but that's a story for a different day
maybe for the bonus show the bonus show
today so great and I don't even have
time to tell you what's on it but trust
me this I can tell you it's tremendous